and I'll give the floor to Madame
fondling for her statement miss youla
crazy doll mr. president ladies and
gentlemen members of the European
Parliament exactly 40 years ago the
first President of the European
Parliament seemed of a is elected and
puts forward her vision of a more
unified and more just Europe it is
thanks to her and all the other European
icons that today I am able to put
forward to you my vision of Europe and
40 years later it is with great pride
that I am able to say finally a woman is
candidate for the presidency of the
European Commission
[Applause]
I am that woman thanks to all of those
women who broke through the barriers and
the conventions I am that woman thanks
to all of those who built a Europe of
peace of unity and a Europe of values it
is this European conviction that has
guided me throughout my life and my
career as a mother as a doctor and also
as a politician it is that courage and
boldness demonstrated by the pioneers
such as Simone a that is at the very
heart of my vision of Europe and it will
be that spirit that will guide the
European Commission that I have the
intention to be the president of and mr.
president ladies and gentlemen members
of the European Parliament the founding
fathers and mothers of Europe from the
ruins and ashes of the world war created
a fantastic new world of peace with a
stronger common market the ability to
work and study and research across belt
borders 500 million Europeans now live
between riga and Emmas or between Athens
and Lisbon in wealth and freedom my
children's generation is able to look
ahead to a Europe which is a home and
they can't really imagine it any other
way and those born into that help
positive generation assumed as parents
that this would always be the case but
today it is now clear that we are going
to have to fight that we're going to
have to ride up for this Europe of ours
the whole world is called upon with
disruptive developments a pace not to
allow this to go by to pass by Europe
globalization of the world economy
the huge digitalization of our world of
work and of course climate change
none of these meta in developments are
new they have been predicted by our
scientists for a long time but the new
thing is that as citizens of Europe
today irrespective of which country we
live in the impact of that is something
that we are feeling in our daily lives
whether it's the Finnish wheat growers
affected by drought or the effects that
are now made palpable in France we are
all experiencing climate change online
banking is now in the daily lives of the
Irish or in Poland people after 20 years
in the workplace are having to take
further training just to remain in the
workplace so we are all feeling this
very close and personal and whether it's
in the schools or hospitals companies in
Europe which having to close we are
experiencing demographic change as well
up close and personal with a feeling of
losing control of looser ties with our
communities none of these challenges
will go away but there have been
different ways to react to these trends
some are turning towards authoritarian
regimes some are buying their global
influence when creating dependencies by
investing in ports and roads and others
are turning towards protectionism none
of these options are for us we want
multilateralism we want fair trade we
defend the rules-based order because we
know it is better for all of us we have
to do it the European Way
but if we are to go down the European
path we must first rediscover our unity
if we are united on the inside
nobody will divide us from the outside
if we close the gaps between us we can
turn tomorrow's challenges in tomorrow's
opportunities honorable members are most
pressing challenge is keeping our planet
healthy this is the greatest
responsibility and opportunity of our
times
I want Europe to become the first
climate neutral continent in the world
by 2050
to make this happen
we must take both steps together our
current goal of reducing our emissions
by 40 percent by 2030 is not enough we
must go further we must strive for more
a two step approach is needed to reduce
co2 emissions by 2030 by 50 if not 55%
the European Union will lead
international negotiations to increase
the level of ambition of other major
economies by 2021 because to achieve
real impact we do not only have to be
ambitious at home we have to do that yes
but the world has to move together to
make this happen I will put forward a
Green Deal for Europe in my first 100
days in office I will put forward the
first-ever European climate law which
will set the 2050 target in law this
increase of ambition will need
investment on a major scale public money
will not be enough I will propose a
sustainable Europe investment plan and
turn parts of the European Investment
Bank into a climate bank this will
unlock 1 trillion euros of investment
over the next decade
it means change all of us and every
sector will have to contribute from
aviation to maritime transport to the
way each of and every one of us travels
and lives emissions must have a price
that changes our behavior to complete
this work and to ensure our companies
can compete on a level playing field I
will introduce carbon board attacks to
avoid carbon leakage but honourable
members what is good for planet must
also be good for our people and our
regions of course I know about the
importance of cohesion funds but we need
more we need a just transition for not
all of our regions have the same
starting point but we all share the same
destination this is why I will propose a
just transition fund to support those
most affected this is the European way
we are ambitious we leave nobody behind
and we offer perspectives if we want to
succeed with this ambitious plan we need
a strong economy because what we want to
spend we have to earn it first for that
we need to strengthen the backbone of
our economy the small and medium-sized
enterprises they are innovative they are
entrepreneurial they are flexible and
agile they create jobs they provide
vocational training to our youth but
they can only do all this if they have
access to capital everywhere in this
huge single market let's get rid of all
the barriers let's open the door
it's finally complete the capital
markets union our small and medium
enterprises deserve it and we need to
work with a stability and growth pact
when vestment and reforms are needed we
should make sure they can be done we
should make use of all the flexibility
allowed in the rules we are proud of our
economy we want to make it stronger but
there's also a clear and simple logic
it's not people that serve our economy
it's the economy that serves our people
in our social market economy we must
reconcile the market with the social
therefore I will refocus our European
semester to make sure we stay on track
with our sustainable development goals
and I will stand for fair Texas weather
for brick and mortar industries or
digital business when the tech giants
are making huge profits in Europe this
is fine because we're an open market and
we like competition but if they are
making these profits by benefiting from
our education system our skilled workers
our infrastructure and our social
security if this is so it is not
acceptable that they make profits but
they are barely paying any taxes because
they play our text system if they want
to benefit they have to share the burden
on rubble members the European Way is
also about using all of our potential
our people our talent our diversity
it is about care creating a fairer and
more equal union this will drive me
forward every single day I am an office
as it has throughout my career we have
come a long way since I was a minister
for Family Affairs and had to fight to
introduce parental pay our access to
child care for families but the fight
for fairness never stops it is still too
difficult for hardworking families to
make ends meet in Europe I want to
ensure that work pays in a social market
economy every person that is working
full-time should earn a minimum wage
that pays for a decent living
therefore we will develop a framework of
course in respect of the different labor
markets but I think the optimal option
is to have collective bargaining by
employers Union and trade union because
they tailor the minimum wage to the
sector or to the region necessary of
course I'm aware there are different
models but we have to create the
framework and I want better protection
for those who lose their job when our
economy takes a severe hit a European
unemployment reinsurance team will
support our economies and our people in
times of external shocks of course there
are national unemployment insurance --is
but a reinsurance scheme for those heavy
external shops is needed in Europe I
also want more equality and fairness for
young people youth unemployment is at
14% in Europe but it ranges from 5
percent to 40 percent in some countries
we cannot accept this young people have
aspirations they want to work they want
to have a future and it is our job to
let them achieve this this is why I will
make sure the youth guarantee which I
started when I was a minister for labour
Affairs in our council is working as
well as it can in every member state and
I will support the European Parliament's
idea to triple the Erasmus boot budget
as part of the next long term budget
we have to care for the most vulnerable
our children we have to fight poverty I
know as a mother of seven that it makes
a difference for the entire life if
children have access to education to
sport to music to healthy food and to a
loving environment we need a child
guarantee to help ensure that every
child in Europe at risk of poverty and
social exclusion has access to the most
basics of Rights like health care and
education
I will it will empower them and it pays
tremendously if we back them when they
are young and this is part of my action
plan to bring our pillar of social
rights to life and I will start at home
by example I will ensure full gender
equality in my College of Commissioners
if member states do not propose enough
female commissioners I will not hesitate
to ask for new names since 1958 there
have been 183 commissioners only 35 were
women there is less less than 20% we
represent half of our population we want
our fair share
we also need to talk openly about
violence against women if one in five
women have already suffered physical or
sexual violence in the European Union
and 55 percent of women have been
sexually harassed this is clearly not a
women's issue I will propose to add
violence against women on the list of EU
crimes defined in the treaty and the
European Union should join the Istanbul
convention I'm convinced if we close
those gaps between us we will emerge
stronger as a union
honorable members the cradle of our
European civilization is Greek
philosophy and Roman law and our
European continent went through its
darkest period when we were ruled by
dictators and rule of law was banished
for centuries
Europeans fought so hard for their
liberty and independence the rule of law
is our best tool to defend these
freedoms and to protect the most
vulnerable in our union this is why
there can be no compromise when it comes
to respecting the rule of law there
never will be
I will ensure that we use our full and
comprehensive toolbox at European level
in addition I fully support an eu-wide
rule of law mechanism and to be clear
the new instrument is not alternative to
the existing instruments but an
additional one the Commission will
always be independent guardian of the
treaty Lady Justice is blind she will
defend the rule of law wherever it is
attacked honourable members the rule of
law is universal it applies to all in
the last five years more than 17,000
people have drowned in the Mediterranean
which has become one of the deadliest
border in the world at sea there is the
duty to save lives
and in our treaties and conventions
there is the legal and moral duty to
respect the dignity of every human being
the European Union can and must defend
these values the European Union needs
humane borders we must save but saving
alone is not enough we must reduce
irregular migration we must fight
smugglers and traffickers its organized
crime we must preserve the right to
asylum and improve the situation of
refugees for example through
humanitarian corridors in close
cooperation with the UNHCR we need
empathy and decisive action I am aware
of how difficult and divisive
discussions on these issues are we need
to address the legitimate concerns of
many and look at how we can overcome our
differences I will propose a new pact on
migration and asylum including the
relaunch of the Dublin reform this will
allow us to return to a fully
functioning Schengen area of free
movement the key driver of our
prosperity security and freedoms a
centerpiece in this ambition is a
reinforced European board and Coast
Guard agencies we need to reach a
standing for of 10,000 Frontex border
guards not by 2027 but way earlier at
least by 2024 we have to modernize we
have to modernize our Asylum system a
common European Asylum system must be
exactly that common we can only have
stable external borders if we give
enough help to member states facing the
most pressure because of where they are
on the map we need solidarity
we need to help each other and to
contribute we need a new way of
burden-sharing
and we must make a fair cooperation
offer to countries of origin and transit
which are in the interest of both sides
diplomacy economic development
investment stability and security are
needed so that people have a perspective
I would like to tell you a story about
perspective four years ago
I was lucky enough to welcome a 19 year
old refugee from Syria into my home and
into my family he spoke no German he was
deeply scarred by his experience of
Civil War and flight today four years
later he's fluent in German he's fluent
in English is of course fluent in Arabic
he is a community leader by day in
vocational training and a student for
his high school degree by night he is an
inspiration for us all and one day he
wants to go home and honorable members
as a defense minister I've been many
times in this war-torn neighborhood I
will never forget the words of former
president of Iraq masoom who said we
want to see more Europe here the world
is calling for you the world needs more
you I believe Europe should have a
stronger and more united voice in the
world and it needs to act fast and that
is why we must have the courage to take
foreign policy decisions by qualified
majority and to stand united behind them
the cornerstone of our collective
defense will always be NATO we will stay
transatlantic and we have to become more
European this is why we created the
European defense Union our work for our
European Union of security and defence
is embedded in comprehensive security
stabilisation always comes with
diplomacy reconciliation and
reconstruction our servicemen and
servicewomen work side by side with
police officers diplomats and
development aid workers and honourable
members
these men and women deserve our utmost
respect and recognition for that
tireless service for Europe I cannot
talk about Europe without talking about
our friends from the United Kingdom for
the very first time in 2016 a Member
State decided to leave the European
Union
[Applause]
this is a serious decision we regret it
but we respected sync them together with
the current government of the United
Kingdom the European Union has worked
hard to organize orderly the orderly
departure of the United Kingdom the
withdrawal agreement concluded with the
government of the United Kingdom
provides certainty web brakes it created
uncertainty in preserving the rights of
citizens and in preserving peace and
stability on the island of Ireland these
two priorities are mine - however I
stand ready for further extension of the
withdrawal date should more time be
required for a good reason
in any case the United Kingdom will
remain our ally our partner and our
friend honourable members when I came to
Strasbourg 13 days ago I promised I'd
come to listen I've heard your concerns
your hopes your expectations the
political guidelines which I sent to you
today reflect our discussions from what
I have heard I've drawn my conclusions
and I've made my decisions first I want
European citizens to play a leading and
active part in building the future of
our union I want them to have their say
at a conference on the future of Europe
to start in 2020 and to run for two
years second I want us to work together
to improve the schvitzing candidate
system we need to make it more visible
to a wider electorate and we need to
address the issue of transnational lists
at the European elections as a
complementary tool of European democracy
and third and third yes I support a
right of initiative for the European
Parliament
when this house acting by majority of
its members adopts resolutions
requesting the Commission to submit
legislative proposals I commit to
responding with a legislative act in
full respect of the proportionality
subsidiarity
and better lawmaking principles I'm
convinced that our stronger partnership
will further help to make people's
voices heard her president mr. president
my father was 15 years old when vile war
that had brought devastation by my
country and displacement and destruction
to our continent ended he often told his
children me and my six siblings about it
above all he told us how significant it
had been that the other countries
reached out a hand to us again to bring
us into the circle of democratic
people's he started in the corner steel
community and said at the outset we're
trading with each other again and if
we're trading then friendships will grow
up and friends will not shoot at each
other he was head of cabanne for the
Thunder cordon in the house town
Commission and later Director General
for competition issues that is why I was
born in Brussels and became European
before later learning that I was German
and a citizen of Lower Saxony and that
is why there is only one thing for me to
unify and strengthen Europe anyone who
wishes to strengthen and help this
Europe of ours to grow and blossom will
find in me a passionate fighter by their
side but anyone who seeks to weaken
split or destroy its values will find in
me a fierce opponent
[Applause]
in his old age at the end of his life my
father's story about Europe had changed
he no longer talked about war so much
he said Europe is like a long marriage
love may not be greater than on the
first day but it gets deeper because we
know that we can rely on each other in
good times and in bad because we know we
can argue but be reconciled again
because we never forget why we formed
this alliance all of us in this room
live in a Europe that has grown up
matured and grown strong with its 500
million inhabitants over 200 million
people voted in the European elections
this Europe has influenced this Europe
wants to take responsibility for itself
and this world that's not always easy I
know it can be painful and difficult but
it is our most noble duty people want to
see that we deliver that we make
progress young people are calling for it
my children quite right they're saying
don't waste time do it and that's what
drives me this is why I need your help
and support and I call on all Europeans
therefore to play their part it is the
most precious thing that we have long
live Europe viva la long live Europe
thank you
get out see
thank you
get out [ __ ] Thank You Madame von der
Leyen thank you for your statement we
now will hear from the group residents
starting with mr. Weber Manfred you have
the floor see I got the stuff on the
line so get that Thank You presidents
miss Fonda Leinen colleagues ladies and
gentlemen after the election of our
president two weeks ago - the time has
now come to elect the President of the
European Commission I'd like to thank
other a funder liner for the ideas
suggestions she shared with us today
about the future of Europe for our group
my group the EPP we are committed to our
electoral promise the commitments we
made to the students of Europe must
guide our work 40 million people voted
for the 138 members of the EPP group
these 40 million citizens expects us to
live up to our commitment that's to say
that the promises we made must be
delivered on a fair Europe with
equitable living conditions for
everybody a fair Europe where we remain
the laboratory of research for the world
further enhancing a position a safe
ensure Europe where we provide secure
borders while at the same time helping
those in need
an open Europe which trades with the
rest of the world and conducts a
partnership with Africa Europe which
protects the environment and the climate
what at the same time protecting the
social consequences Louis laFonda
line-in is above all the Christian
Democrat she's a convinced European
which is one of the reasons why we will
together with her be translating into
reality our electoral promise and we
will be extending our full support to
order of underline and today I would
like to extend my thanks to Frank's
timmermans but I go to Scott Keller and
other members of this house for the
determined campaigns they wage for the
European Parliament I was honored to be
one of those candidates with them in a
fair competition in which we will try to
fight to defend our values and to
convince people while at the same time
respecting the raziel
201 million people took part in the
European elections that's a genuine
festival of democracy and all of them
shared one wish wish to see a more
democratic Europe developments in recent
days haven't always comforted that
belief amongst people we've seen
examples of a criticism from political
parties and that's something which many
people view is damaging for democracy so
what's happened over the last few days
has caused damage however I don't think
we can put that damage right by causing
further damage Durer Europe must now be
in a position to act Europe must be
stable this is why two weeks ago my
group supported the candidacy of david
says solely as president of the European
Parliament and I expect today that his
group and others will support our
candidate the presidency of the European
Commission wasn't a funder lion I would
like to reiterate we have to be able to
rely on each other this is the only way
that Europe can succeed obviously over
the next five years we have to continue
to work under the principle of a united
Europe we need to ensure that we have
better scrutiny of the implementation of
European law and an enhanced and
consolidated system of its encanta dad's
we have to ensure that deals cut in
smoky back rooms are a thing of the past
this is why I and my group will fight
with determination to ensure the creator
a Europe for the people for us as
Christian Democrats today must be a new
start we have to roll up our sleeves and
get down to work with Ursula Thunder
lion as president of the Commission
thank you
Thank You mr. Weber mrs. Garcia Paris
for the associates in Democrat group
gracias president Thank You president
madam von der Leyen today is an
important day the future of the European
Union is in our hands and my political
group which has been there since the
very beginning has a pro-european ISM in
its veins and want to Hertz to help to
build our Europe we accept our
responsibility towards the European
citizens who put their trust in us and
that's why we will act responsibly we
want to be sure that over the coming
five years we will be able to continue
to build a project and a sustainable
future for all Europeans I would just
like to recall a pro-european on a day
such as today who took the floor in this
Parliament 40 years ago Willy Brandt in
the plenary just after the first direct
elections in 1979 he launched an appeal
which I think we should recall today he
regretted the fact that although
democracy he regretted the fact that
democracy was moving so slowly in Europe
and he also regretted the fact that the
European institutions still seemed to be
too distant from the people however
members of the European Parliament were
able to get down to work despite the
geographical or ideological differences
they wanted to solve people's problems
and to try to connect with young people
40 years later what his words are as
relevant as ever we are socialists want
to continue to ensure that we make
faster progress with democracy in Europe
we had placed our faith in this bits in
candidate
but procedure and were in favor into
transnational lists however European
democracy can't go into reverse oui
madame Thunder lion want to want to
ensure that we see this bits in
candidate process in 2020 for Europe has
to be able to solve people's problems we
have to be able to face up to the
challenges we face today and we need to
ensure this is the case before we can
support you for Commission President we
have to know that youth will be possible
to leave a change that citizens want to
bring about the transformation that
young people are demanding we think
you're moving in the right direction
there are advances now however we need
to see things be improperly implemented
we want to see ambition in our
legislation we need to also set binding
objectives to ensure that we can meet
our objectives in cutting emissions by
2030 nobody has to be left behind and so
this means that you have to ensure that
we have a fund for a fair transition we
also want to see an investment plan for
sustainable Europe it has to be clear
that a large part of this has to be done
through public investment when we set
the European sustainable development
goals and the European semester these
can't just be seen as a principle we
have to set out clear criteria and
indicators
you can't punish those governments who
are invested in an economic transverse
transformation which is supporting its
people and which is laying the
foundations for a sustainable future
therefore we will insist and this is
something that you set out in your
letter we want to see economic
flexibility and an unemployment
guarantee Europe has to take care of its
most vulnerable citizens that's why our
political group will always support the
European social pillar and more
specifically the child guarantee and the
youth guarantee Madame von der Leyen we
need to see a stronger stance against
poverty in general everybody has to play
their role in creating these policies we
also have to ensure that we make proper
use of technological changes you've said
that you want there to be a shared
effort have you come up with any
specific figures on this you also said
that we have to improve the situation
for workers from new platforms here you
have a political group that would
support a directive on these issues then
when it comes to gender equality I think
we are on the same Lautrec my political
group has gender equality as a clear
political priority we want to have
binding gender quotas this is something
that would be a very good start if you
were to have our gender equality with
your permission we also want to see a
new mechanism
I think a lot of people in this room
would like to see that you plan to be as
as demanding as the previous Commission
and in particular as friends timmermans
was when it comes to the rule of law
perhaps you could explain except to what
you'll do that and we also want to see
more solidarity between member states
and also a reform of Dublin we need more
solidarity we have to talk about
humanitarian corridors we can't just
strengthen security or to strengthen
Frontex objectives we have to save
people's lives and in order to do that
we need to have some kind of rescue
system which would criminalize those who
are involved in humanitarian rescue
operations or those who are victim of
circumstance
Madame von der Leyen we're here to
listen to you we don't want any kind of
institutional crisis which will just
further delay the changes that Europe
needs to see but what we do want are
guarantees that the coming years will
ensure that Europe will be able to take
the measures it needs to my group will
take it position this afternoon thinking
about what's the best for Europe the men
and women of Europe want to regain their
hope in the European project and we of
course want to build more and better
Europe
get out ship president lishala thank you
mr. Jonas you have a domino pressured
into the sub not parliament mrs. von der
Leyen this Parliament has never before
been so important and has been aware of
the responsibility that his opponent
shoulders the Council that put your name
forward is split there is a global
package there is a compromise package
that came about after much debate and I
think that the it's a shame that the
balance between East and West Europe
hasn't been upheld
obviously if the College of
Commissioners were to be better balanced
that would be a good thing now you have
been nominated and it is because of the
responsibilities that you have entered
entered into we want Europe to make
progress and we have high expectations
after the elections all European
citizens wished to have a fitting
candidate system and to enable them to
select and elect the next president of
the Commission but that hasn't happened
now you've talked about a conference for
the future of Europe this is going to
make the democratization process
possible and we know exactly what's been
going on we've seen the pro European
groups and negotiation and we have put
together a common platform in order for
your election to go through we do need a
common working framework between
Parliament and Commission with clear
objectives set out for the following
five years and our group is prepared to
support you if you are able to promise
this renewal for Europe the deal that
you put forward today is a clear one and
the pro Europeans will certainly be
giving you their support and we are able
for European citizens to build a Europe
that is able once again to garner
support and faith before the elections
it was said that there's an awful lot of
anti Panem anti-european ISM in this
Parliament and that's going to make it
very difficult for Europe but that
hasn't proven to be the case Pro
European forces in this house remain
strong and now the millions of Europe
Europeans that voted for us must not be
disappointed they expect of us that we
will uphold the rule of law we mustn't
disappoint millions of young people that
voted
and the appeal that you have made for
the climate for good cooperation between
the generations these are things that
must go ahead and we mustn't disappoint
entrepreneurs and farmers there must be
this possibility for people to live in
an open world in a way that is worthy of
people that is ecological that moves
forward but it also takes into account
new technologies and doesn't exclude
digitalization it is an important
component and must be limited the single
market mustn't just be a bureaucratic
arrangement it must make sure that
well-being and wealth is spread and we
expect to view misses fun denying that
you will lead in a pro-european manner
Europe isn't just an administrative
setup it pursues a Polock political
objective and if you are to be confirmed
by this house and I hope you will be
then you will often hear that there are
some things that can't be changed but
this is a change that we must see Thank
You mr. lombija our shared house is on
fire
a fire caused by a deregulated climate
biodiversity which is collapsing and
natural resources become ever scarcity
this fire is further fueled by the new
liberal revolution and the technical
technological revolution this fire is
also burning up the rule of law and
fundamental freedoms faced with this
three-pronged emergency it's no longer
enough just to state our good intent or
our determination we need a ferocious
attempt to change direction even if that
means overturning the efforts of those
who want to defend the status quo
the green youth of free European
Alliance group was elected in May with
an agenda for change we wanted to count
on new misses underlined three weeks ago
you didn't have the faintest idea that
you would soon be holding the highest
office in the European Union in other
words you've been on a pretty steep
learning curve your performance last
week didn't convince us you didn't seem
to show enough urgency nor indeed a
determination to redirect the ship of
the European Union the speech you've
just made and the written documents
backing it up are a big step forward I
would like to commend your commitment
supported by clear examples to move
towards parity for men and women
I was also delighted to hear you say
that you're personally committed to
reducing by 2030 our co2 emissions by
half you've taken up the green idea of a
carbon tax a lot borders as well as the
idea of a trans European unemployment
fund which has been a taboo in Europe
little family up until now however
despite this commitments what you said
falls far short of what we want let me
give you a few examples so for example
why have you decided to raise our
efforts to meet the climate challenge in
two different stages if we look at the
details of what you wrote to tubeless
your groups you we see the idea of
conditionality emerging once again in
other words we will only move when
others are willing to move as well you
also quite rightly underlined that the
ecological transition shouldn't leave
anybody behind however you'd agree that
if the cost of carbon increases
everybody including the poorest in
society will be affected the response to
that is not as you say a European
adjustment fund but on the contrary a
root and branch reform of our tax system
serves to ensure that finally we moved
towards greater equity the environment
is more than just the climate you didn't
speak at all about biodiversity or ever
squirrel resources such as fresh water
or farming land the European farming
Policy Act or through policy has a
disastrous effect on Europe and it's the
biggest budget item but that's once
again a taboo for you once again your
ambitions
short because of entrenched interests
for the time being we we see all sorts
of European instruments which continue
to exhaust the planet's resources while
exacerbating inequality you have said
that the treaty should include clauses
referring to sustainable development as
it already does however you very very
cautiously refrain from the same ia's
clauses should be binding in particular
when it comes to preventing beneficial
treatment for so-called investors nor
have I heard you question the
fundamental idea the very scandal of
this fortress Europe it's quite
unacceptable that the European Union
continues to rely on failed States and
rogue space to guarantee the
impermeability of its borders the cost
of this is massive violations of human
rights carried out by armed bands or the
so called Libyan border force and coast
guards which have funds with European
money you have suggested a migration
pact miss von der Leyen let me remind
you madam such a pact already exists it
was adopted by a majority of five groups
in the European part let's not reinvent
the wheel please take her over a
proposal and fight for it in the council
when it comes to the rule of law your
language was perhaps strong but your
proposals remain very vague the time now
has come to fundamentally change things
we have to ensure that European values
be respected everywhere rather than
simply playing into the hands of youth
heads of state and government like in
Hungary or Poland who continue to
regular violate European fundamental
freedoms and the separation of powers
what we need is a clear change of
direction in the face of the triple
emergency facing as environment social
and climate what you seem to be
suggesting is incremental changes and
all sorts of vague ideas I'm sure you'll
understand it at the present time the
ecologist in the European Parliament are
not willing to support you to head up
the European Commission miss von der
Leyen let remind you that since the
elections our group has done its utmost
to ensure that we can establish a
pro-european and pro-change majority in
this house such an enterprise takes time
your insistence
calling for a vote today deprives us of
that value time available time you might
have shown great courtesy to us but we
haven't really seen a clear commitment
to such an alliance on the contrary you
seem to be willing to accept support
from wherever it comes including from
the nationalist members in this house
and that's something we simply can't
agree on as I said to you a week ago the
haggling starts when somebody says no so
let me assure you that we'll be willing
to support you whenever your proposals
live up to the enormous challenges
facing us in the fields of democracy the
environment and social affairs in other
words proposals designed to tack the
existential problems facing our
continents all right then
thank you mr. Morton over to you mr.
president colleagues this Minister fonda
lion today in this house we have a very
important decision to make on a person a
person who will become the president of
the European Commission which is of
great importance to the European Union
and the member states and therefore we
will have to make this decision very
carefully it is only somebody of the
highest calibre who would be able to
take that post minister von der Leyen
I have great respect for you as a person
but in our group we have looked into
this carefully and feel that the
requirement of the post are not one that
you're able to meet let me just set that
out first of all we Germans we have a
way of doing politics and we have had
some experience of that back home over
years when you were family Minister
Minister for work and social matters and
then most recently defence minister and
in none of those offices were you
serving the interests of the German
people and did justice to the jobs I
will spare people here an explicit list
of all of your failings you save so much
money
destroyed our army you it has never been
so badly equipped and it is basically
incapable of carrying out defense
actions and
nobody will rue your departure were you
to become Commission president back home
and it is important to take that into
account the German government in earlier
times has had post in Brussels but there
is nothing that we see that speaks in
favor of the Commission presence see
being done by you better than your
previous jobs there is a long list of
vague promises that you made and often
they included their exact opposites and
that is not just given rise to criticism
by us but by others article 7 procedures
against Poland and Hungary being upheld
in the ECR group you said the rule of
law was important and tolerance of
migrants but these are current these are
their obvious contradictions and there
is now a whole panoply of nice-sounding
ideas that you put forward you've been
on a media to a classical mainstream
politician making empty promises playing
a kind of Jacqueline Hyde game with the
groups in the vain hope that at the end
of it all there will be sufficient votes
that will be garnered for your election
the problem is that you don't have a
convincing vision of a modern Europe
that will serve the people of Europe a
clever way of focusing on the core
aspects of that Europe in contrary to
that you talk about more competence for
the center
and talking on people's behalf so when
it comes to the questions that I put in
the conference of Presidents last week
you first of all didn't answer two of
the questions and the third question you
answered in a very unsatisfactory way so
the kind of performance you put in today
is not one that we find persuasive in
the idea group and this is why we will
vote against you thank you you get out
yeah Thank You mr. feit Oh si Grazia
Thank You president I listened very
closely to what you had to say mrs. von
der Leyen
and also I listened to you in our group
meeting I do have to say that in your
words today I would say that your
positions have changed rather from what
we heard last week I would just like to
start off by picking up on something
that you've said a number of times over
the last few days and weeks
you said the Parliament is the heart of
democracy I would say that at the moment
things can only work if everyone
respects the system you talked about
gender equality about the importance of
having a woman as head of Commission for
the first time but that's just after
what we saw yesterday evening in this
Parliament we saw a woman who was
already a prime minister in her own
country it wasn't chosen as a president
of the Employment Committee and this is
something that's illogical and
incomprehensible and I'm recalling this
because I think it's important when
we're talking about rules we can't be
hypocritical
we can't ask for consensus or for the
Parliament to play a rule if we don't
respect the de haan system or if these
kind of events come about and in the
these recent hours you've written a
number of letters words may disappear
but letters remain and so we read very
carefully what you wrote to renew and
the Socialists and so this morning we
would like to see some clarifications
for example mrs. Garcia Perez asked you
for clarifications about the rule of law
mechanism we would also like to have
some clarifications from you on this in
your reply over the last five years
we've seen certain methods that have
been invented by mister timmermans and
so I think we're talking about different
things and I think we don't have any
clarity about this rule of law mechanism
that you talked about it's also
important to talk about climate change
obviously there are some positive points
on climate change you set out things
such as the trendy just transition fund
in order to help to mitigate the effects
of climate change a sustainable
investment bank making use of private
capital but once again you're talking
about targets and
we have these very excellent ambitions
but we have no idea how to achieve them
everything seems to be rather confused
if I've understood correctly you're
suggesting that the target should be 50%
last week it was 55% it's quite a
significant difference when it comes to
the objective we're trying to achieve
your declaration seems to be one of
intentions some countries as you know
still once they're dependent on coal
there are important issues such as ones
our group has always spoken out about
you talk about a European minimum wage
that would and guaranteeing all young
people a job what resources are you
going to use for that and what about the
roles of the individual member states
and all of this you also gave a very
nice example this morning about this
refugee who came to Germany and you
welcomed him it was a very nice story
but we're not just talking about
refugees we also have migrants we have
illegal immigrants and perhaps again you
could provide clarifications on this
last week you said something quite
serious we think somebody who is under
inquire in our country because they
didn't respect the orders issued by the
and national authorities and helped
people flee Italian forces of Lordan
order this morning the libre committee
is talking about inviting that person to
a hearing so I'd like to have clear
responses from you on all of this as
well that will help us to make
legislation that we need to take at the
end of this meeting in algorri meeting
thank you [ __ ] on thank you mr.
Suder on a Leila parole
Thank You president Thank You president
miss von der Leyen we heard a lot in
your address about the men and women the
citizens of Europe over the last few
days I've had hundreds or thousands
indeed emails and I'm sure other
colleagues have as well talking about
your nomination I think it's important
the people of Europe the European demos
be given the floor I'd like to quote
from one of these emails the wrote the
person who wrote it said that as a voter
I insist that the European Parliament
should ensure that one of the Spitz and
candidates be elected as president of
the European Commission and the woman
who wrote the email continued by writing
that the appointments of the German
defense minister to the presence of the
European Commission would in my view
have fatal consequences in terms of the
future of the European Union confirming
a trend towards greater militarization
and isolation clearly there is still
criticism about the way in which your
nomination has been put forward and I'd
like to refer back to the meeting we had
last week you came along and met the
left-wing group in the European
Parliament you said that your vision of
the European Union it became clear to us
that your vision is quite different from
ours let me explain the ours is the only
group which is fully determined to
reject a continuation of existing
policymaking when you talk about the
future of the European Union I think the
time has come for us to bring an end to
break a clear break with austerity this
new liberal policy should pursued for so
many years
the fact is colleagues national budgets
are continuing to sit restricted to cuts
and this has prevented us investing in
public projects and investigation in
education in Social Affairs and in
hard-hitting measures to help fight
climate change the people who suffer
most from these neoliberal policies are
the men and women who live throughout
the European Union miss von der Leyen if
we really are to fight the climate
emergency we have to act now and if we
want to bring about fundamental changes
to our economic structures we have to
start by investing now
anybody who wants to guarantee security
for the European Union must start by
making a clean break with this misguided
austerity policy 113 million people
these are official figures from the
European Commission currently live below
the poverty line in the European Union
we have a clear expectation from any
candor of the presence of the European
Commission we were more than just
flowery words we want clear commitments
you have to make it clear understood you
have to make it clear you're committed
to rolling out a social offensive for
the European Union my objective you
should be saying is that in five years
time nobody in Europe regardless of how
old they are of where they live in
Europe should see their very existence
being threatened all everybody in Europe
should have a dignified existence so for
example in the field of tax policy
unfortunately you've been once again
very vague if there's no point in taking
kids gloves when it comes to fighting
for tax justice our expectation of a
credible candidate for the presidency of
the Commission is that they have the
determination and courage to state
clearly they want to bring an end to tax
dumping that they want to close tax
havens within the European Union and
that they want to ensure that those with
wealth be subjected to fair taxes so
that is to ensure that we can achieve
genuine tax justice
whereas apparently further billions of
euros are now to be invested in the
European defense sector you've made that
clear in your address that's money which
would be far better spent on education
training and social justice that money
won't be going to Social Affairs will be
going into modern weapons systems some
people are even dreaming about a
European Space Army commit to me that
sounds more like a nightmare than a
dream but the idea of a European army or
an army of Europeans you're just playing
with words but your objective is clear
what you want to do is to enhance the
military side of the European Union to
back up your foreign policy this is
something which our group in the
European Parliament decisively we call
for a Europe which tries to help solve
conflicts with the first step towards an
international disarmament conference
my final points I'd like to make it
clear that the European external border
is currently the world's most dangerous
border and this for me is a clear sign
of the failure of European politicians
the fact that everyday people continue
to drown in the Mediterranean whereas
those few people in certain Member
States who continue to defend the
universal human rights are thrown into
prison ms von der Leyen we listen Claire
clearly to what you said I believe that
our plan for the future of the European
Union a social European Union European
Union based on climate justice and peace
I don't think that our vision of Europe
is compatible what you've told us today
so unfortunately we won't be able to
support this evening thank you Mr Farage
on behalf of non-attached members well I
may be speaking from the back of the
chamber today but as I predicted last
time I was here in the European
elections the brexit party were very
much to the front of the elections and
massive massive winners and I come back
to a place that has been humbled and
humiliated the European Council
stitch-up has rendered this place
impotent until today when you've got
some real power if you choose to use it
what you've seen from Ursula Van der
Leyen
today is an attempt for the European
Union to take control of every single
aspect of our lives
she wants to build a centralised
undemocratic updated form of communism
that will render nation state
Parliament's where the state controls
everything
when nation state Parliament's where
nation state Parliament's will cease to
have any relevance at all I have to say
from our perspective in some ways I'm
really rather pleased because you've
just made brexit a lot more popular in
the United Kingdom thank God we're
leaving
it is in the aspects of defense that I
think people's mind should be focused
she's a fanatic for building a European
army but she's not alone when it's
completed
NATO will cease to exist or have any
relevance in Europe at all and of course
not to be left out of this French
president Emmanuel macron on Bastille
Day last Sunday stood at the front of an
open-top car with his nascent European
defense force behind him looking for all
the world like an updated version of
Napoleon being no doubt be and no doubt
five years of these people the European
defense union will be complete and what
is there for defense can also be used
for attack and you as a house will have
no control over it
vote against this nominee strike a blow
for democracy strike a blow for your
citizens thank you Mr Farage mr.
president yeah this short I would like
now to give the floor to miss von der
Leyen asking her to respond to the
comments made by the heads of critical
groups
go ahead madam thank you president to be
quite honest with you having listened to
the last speaker that provides further
proof have just important how important
is that we continue to work closely with
our British colleagues in the future but
I think Mr Farage we can probably do
with that what you've got to say here
and that's what I find beautiful about
Europe here in our Europe countries come
together they come together on a
voluntary basis nobody has forced them
to come together all our countries know
that strength is in unity by working
together we can defend the values which
are close to all of our hearts and which
brought us together the great challenges
facing us in the world are so
enormous that none of us alone can face
up to them only by working together by
cooperating can we develop the strength
the soft power which is uniquely
European and which is at the very heart
of our European values that's the source
of our strength that's why it's possible
for us to talk about an optimistic
future this is why it's so important
that we deploy our strength to guarantee
a better future for our children
let me now pick up on some of the
subjects referred to the social market
economy this is one of the great
characteristics that you connect unique
characteristics of the European Union
this powerful link between a strong
economy and our other values everybody
knows however that in this economy
everybody has to work hard and we have
to ensure the fruits of our hard work be
given back to the people that's the key
idea of the social market economy the
social pillar of the social market
cotton market economy is something which
is supported by the Commission the
Parliament and the council there's a
clear commitment to continue to support
this system we have to work with
determination to defend that obviously
when we're still far from perfect but
we're determined to identify
shortcomings in the social pillar so as
to correct them and that must be one of
our overarching priorities we've heard
as well about sustainability directors
here once again these are like motives
on a policy making sustainability
objectives surely are something which
all of us must support I think it must
be clear to everybody now that the clock
is ticking time is running out our
planet needs help urgently we our whole
life and society is built on natural
resources which are under threat we have
to ensure that we can deal with these
resources in a sustainable prospective
way this is why it's so important that
we all recognize the value of
sustainability objectives and we should
all do our utmost to pursue them as far
as the progressive approaches can
turn the two-step approach is concerned
we have to ensure those two steps being
rolled out in parallel this is why
recently I've said that we have to start
by tackling this in the European
Parliament however we all know that we
need major players in the world if we
are to move forward with these
objectives this is why it's important
that the European Union can and must
take a leadership role that's the only
way to bring about change the Paris
climate agreement represented a unique
coming together of the powerful in the
world let's continue to draw on the
spirit of Paris the ideas of Paris to
try to defend our future
the second enormous challenge facing us
is digitalization here once again we
have to stand united on the one hand we
need to be able to draw on those people
in society who are able to thrive with
digital the new digital world who
promote our economy at the same time we
have to ensure that the digital economy
be protected with ethical rules
concerning artificial intelligence
cyberspace we have to ensure that we
have robust measures so as to ensure
that that protects everybody and we as
Europeans have to become major players
in the cyber world we know there are
many risks in the cyber world major
risks for our economy or indeed major
risks for our society here once again
none of our states alone are able to
face up to those challenges only by
working together can we succeed in
laying the foundations of a secure
future that what our which our people
deserve the human dimension of
digitalization must be the primary
objective our economy we have to protect
our people somebody who works must be
given protection
we now have to find ways of ensuring
that the values which have always
protected workers in the existing
economy be transferred to the digital
economy how can we defend platform
workers cloud economy workers we have to
ensure that we can transfer that
protection for the benefit of all of our
citizens ladies and gentlemen listen to
all the speakers very clearly one of her
mr. Morton speaking of my sales quite
relieved to hear that you will be voting
for me since everything you said goes
contrary to my deepest values
[Applause]
chairman turmeric esta I have a request
to speak a point of order regarding the
rules mr. Simms what yeah next to me I
would like to refer to an except an
article one full